you said that there are moments in
history of physics
and maybe mathematical physics or even
mathematics where
breakthroughs happen and then a flurry
of progress follows
so if you look back through the history
of physics
what moments stand out to you as
important such breakthroughs
where a flurry of progress follows so
the big famous one is 1920s
the invention of quantum mechanics where
you know in
about five or ten years lots of stuff
got figured out
that's now quantum mechanics can you
mention the people involved yeah that
would be kind of the
schrodinger heisenberg you know einstein
had been a key figure
originally planck then dirac was a
little bit later
that was something that happened at that
time that sort of before my time right
in my time was in the 1970s
uh there was this sort of realization
that quantum field theory
was actually going to be useful in
physics and uh
qcd quantum carbon dynamics theory of
quarks and gluons and so on
was really getting started and uh there
was again
sort of big flurry of things happened
then i happened to be a teenager at that
time
and happened to be uh really involved in
physics
and so i got to be part of that which
was really cool
who were the key figures aside from your
young souls
at that time you know who won the nobel
prize for qcd okay
people david gross frank wilcheck you
know um
david politzer the people who are the
sort of the slightly older generation
dick feynman murray girl man
people like that uh who were
steve weinberg gerard
younger he's in the younger group
actually but um
these are these are all you know
characters who are involved
i mean it was uh you know it's funny
because those are all people
who are kind of in my time i know them
and they don't seem like
sort of uh historical uh you know iconic
figures they seem
more like everyday characters so to
speak
um and uh so it's always you know when
you look at history
from long afterwards it always seems
like
everything happened instantly um and
that's usually not the case there was
usually a long buildup but
usually there's you know there's some
methodological thing happens
and then there's a whole bunch of
low-hanging fruit to be picked and
that usually lasts five or ten years you
know we see it today with machine
learning
and you know deep learning neural nets
and so on
you know methodological advance things
actually started working in you know
2011 2012 and so on
and uh you know there's been this sort
of rapid uh
picking of low-hanging fruit which is
probably
you know some significant fraction of
the way
way done so to speak do you think
there's a key moment like if i had to
really introspect like what was the key
moment for the deep learning
quote-unquote revolution i mean it's
probably the alex and that business alex
now with imagenet
so is there something like that with
physics where
so deep learning neural networks have
been around for a long time
there's a bunch of 1940s yeah there's a
bunch of little pieces that came
together
and then all of a sudden everybody's
eyes lit up
like wow there's something here like
even just
looking at your own work just your
thinking about the universe that there's
simple rules can create complexity
you know at which point was there a
thing where your eyes light up
it's like wait a minute there's
something here is it the very first
idea or is it some moment
along the line of implementations and
experiments and so on
there's a couple of different stages to
this i mean one is the
think about the world computationally
you know can we use
programs instead of equations to make
models of the world
that's something that i got interested
in in the at the beginning of the 1980s
you know i did a bunch of computer
experiments uh you know when i first did
them
i didn't really i s i could see some
significance to them but
it took me a few years to really say wow
there's a big important phenomenon here
that lets sort of complex things arise
from very simple programs
um that kind of happened back in 1984 or
so
then you know a bunch of other years go
by then i start actually doing
a lot of much more systematic computer
experiments and things and find out that
the
you know this phenomenon that i could
only have said occurs in one particular
case
is actually something incredibly general
and then that led me to this thing
called principle of computational
equivalence
and that was a long story and then you
know
as part of that process i was like okay
you can make
simple programs can make models of
complicated things
what about the whole universe that's our
sort of ultimate example of a
complicated thing
yeah and so i got to thinking you know
could we use these ideas
to to study fundamental physics uh you
know i happen to know a lot about
you know traditional fundamental physics
my um
uh my first you know i had a bunch of
ideas about how to do this in the early
1990s
i made a bunch of technical progress i
figured out a bunch of things i thought
were pretty interesting
you know i wrote about them back in
2002. with the new kind of science in
the cellular automatic world and
right there's echoes in the cellular
automotive world with your
new wolfram physics project world
we'll get to all that allow me to sort
of romanticize a little more on the
philosophy of science
uh so thomas kuhn philosopher science
describes
that you know the progress in science is
made with
uh these paradigm shifts and so to link
on the
original line of discussion do you agree
with this view
that there is revolutions in science
that just kind of flip the table what
happens is
it's a different way of thinking about
things it's a different methodology for
studying things
and that opens stuff up this is this
idea of uh
he's a famous biographer but i think
it's called the innovators
the biographer of steve jobs with albert
einstein oh yeah
he also wrote a book i think it's called
the innovators where it
discusses uh how a lot of uh
the innovations in the history of
computing has been done by groups
there's a complicated group dynamic
going on
but there's also a romanticized notion
that the individual
is at the core of the revolution like
where does your sons
fall is is uh ultimately like
one person responsible for these
revolutions that
that creates the spark or one or two
whatever but
or is it just the big mush and mess and
chaos
of people interacting of personalities
interact i think it ends up being like
many things there's leadership
and there ends up being it's a lot
easier for one person to have a crisp
new idea than it is for a big committee
to have a crisp new idea
and um i think you know but i think it
can happen that
you know you have a great idea but the
world isn't ready for you
for it and um you know you can you can i
mean
this has happened to me plenty right
it's you know you have an idea it's
actually a pretty good idea
but things aren't ready either either
you're not really ready for it
or the ambient world isn't ready for it
and it's hard to get the thing to
to get traction
you